my name's Tom and I've come here today
to come clean about what I do for money
basically I use my mouth in strange ways
in exchange for cash I usually do this
kind of thing in seedy downtown bars and
on street corners so this might not be
the most appropriate setting but I'd
like to give you guys a bit of a
demonstration about what I do
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
and now for my next number I'd like to
return to the classics we're gonna take
it back back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
son thank you very much TEDx if you guys
haven't figured it out already
my name is Tom Thumb and I'm a beatboxer
which means all the sounds that you just
heard were made entirely using just my
voice and the only thing was my voice
and I can assure you and I'm very very
stoked
Gus it's important for everything's
great look at this mom I made it I'm
very very stoked to be here today you
know like representing my kinfolk and
all those that haven't managed to make a
career out of an innate ability for
inhuman noise making ah because you know
it is a bit of a niche market and
there's not much work going on
especially where I'm from you know I'm
from Brisbane which is a great city to
live in
you all right most the brisbin's here
that's good know you know I'm from
Brizzy which is a great city to live in
but you know let's be honest it's not
exactly the cultural hub of the southern
hemisphere so I do a lot of my work
outside Brisbane and outside Australia
and so the pursuit of this crazy passion
of mine has enabled me to see so many
amazing places in the world so I'd like
to share with you if I may my
experiences so ladies and gentlemen I
would like to take you on a journey
throughout the continents and throughout
sound itself we start our journey in the
central deserts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Germany
[Applause]
party-party yeah
and before we reach our final
destination ladies and gentlemen I would
like to share with you some technology
that I brought all the way from the
thriving metropolis of Brisbane these
things in front of me here are called
chaos pads and they allow me to do a
whole lot of different things with my
voice for example the one on the left
here allows me to add a little bit of
reverb to myself which gives me that
[Music]
flavor and the other ones here you know
I can use them in unison to mimic the
effect of a drum machine or something
like that I can sample in my own sounds
and I can play it back just by hitting
the pads here
[Music]
[Music]
I'll way too much time on my hands and
last but not least the one on my right
here allows me to loop
whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo my voice so with all
that in mind ladies and gentlemen I
would like to take you on a journey to a
completely separate part of Earth as I
transform the Sydney Opera House into a
smokey downtown jazz bar alright boys
take it away ladies and gentlemen I'd
like to introduce to you a very special
friend of mine
one of the greatest double bassist I
know just the smokey Jefferson let's
take a walk come on baby
[Music]
hi ladies and gentlemen I'd like to
introduce you the star of the show one
of the greatest jazz legends of all time
music lovers and jazz lovers of light
please give a warm round of applause for
the one and only mr. peeping tom take
away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
you